good pass is permission to move in and
around the hood I feel like I sort of
got one but not for one so today is all
about getting a full hood pass so I
bring my bloody got to North Carolina
and then I got my boy Marty free Boyd
models in Jersey we hit one of my most
good as friends Stevie J and why you saw
huddled up on the couch touching thighs
it I mean I definitely didn't know what
the season raiment was I didn't know I
didn't know if another humming was in
the bathrooms and coming out or anything
like that but listen listen break down
to them whatever the pass is good passes
like this one I'm vouching for you you
feel me
anything you do is a representation of
me don't do no weird don't do no buster
don't do no hook that and you'll be
straight how much is a frown here then
you ask me but that's that that's real
specific I don't know name again do dot
B dot I turned that fat bro to P duck
duck get you shot oh yeah - what's your
Governor on Brian's mind yeah all right
first off my love a martini though
that's cool right and a martini both
yeah you like getting drugged and I
smoked I'm not a drinker well a martini
so your new name is the exact exact
exactly I'm bad Dan off your mother hat
yeah you're gonna get off this your name
what is your name zigzag no no no what
is your name my name is Shawn
oh yeah gareki
you got to be able to answer under
pressure and the rest our name is
baseball any time you say it it's like a
cold word everything just kind of
settles like oh he knows a homie he cool
if you're in the area and you said it
nickname and that nickname doesn't
register you can agitate some things
what if somebody else has your nickname
nobody else has my anything and all
other hoods and Los Angeles has money
today so in a way the nickname is the
past
guys I feel like you know we don't put
in our time we've heard y'all out with
digested it mentally we deserve our hood
passes
y'all agree that's a yes perfect so now
we got Stevie J in the hood pass we're
doing everything I dreamed of as an
adjacent but now I'm having my hood
moment terrible good homie got blob -
I'll do it in the fridge I love it
don't let stop flossing donut out is you
running out here man
check it out what's up I'm gonna can I
get a glazed donut
no you're gonna be like gonna be like
what's that glaze hitting folk okay
now see that is kind of good thing
what's that glazed donut hidden for
homie zigzag real asshole now let me get
a twist what guess what guess what guess
what guess what guess what
don't do that dude perfect okay let me
get two switches a black and mouth yeah
minors welcome noodles for trying to
hear I blow it for me I don't never
bought a little oh well my noodle you
see y'all see him try to blow my noodle
try yeah
guys don't touch my guys I like to get
you shot that Becca give me shot eight
time you two got shot today
what does this mean I don't matter just
do it now your do-over
we pull up to the liquor back hug now we
hear if you look around everybody here
who it including y'all good good what's
that broke the hoodie showed up and
checked us some random dudes to start
walking up to us he literally walked
into the scene and was like who are you
and that's when I knew sketch over I
will show you something comical push the
losers give this real start off that's
cool shoot I had to literally just
become a black male talking to a black
male hey Brooke Donald Trump I know I
know you know we just have to make a
common ground having a real fast because
I knew that if I didn't say the right
things
I might have to catch his face for those
who don't know that means kid knocked
the out
bill who sent you over here who told you
they coming over exploit so they should
know immediately I'm on the way so he
gave Russell her pass earlier and so
part of his hood past tourists coming
here where we was doing community that
brother looked mad but then Stevie J had
all the answers all the homeboys to
reference all the streets
I'm baseball off from a tree gangsta
okay peez oh well he's it so he's
driving for shot with you later
if you down can you just give my show of
her pass hey it's your boy mr. white EMF
also known as king we don't crash on
soccer at the world-famous liquor bank
yall already know what it is good bad
I'm very much a Jason well a couple
hours I thought I was hurt but then all
that happened I was like you know what
James you and Jason gonna love
[Music]
[Applause]